mark Stein of the New York Times is
locked in on the Association and has
been for a very long time covered the
NBA since 1994 and the senior NBA
reporter of the New York Times back here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you mark
I'm good rich do I need to report what
I'm wearing is that part of the sure
what do you got
mark I mean I know you're probably
sheltered in place there in the city but
what are you gone
got on a Fela tennis hoodie to pretend
that I'm a pro tennis player which I
really not my games nowhere near good
enough to justify the hoodie but I'm
pretending right and I got a and I got a
Cal State Fullerton had on direct my
school attaboy
very very good so what are you hearing
about the NBA and and and games and I
know things certainly in the city are
particularly dire but again that where
we are talking sports we're in the toy
department of the sports world right now
is it possible the NBA could return us
to that spot do you think I have to say
I'm a pessimist by nature so I've been
pretty cool on it throughout now in
league circles there certainly bandying
about every conceivable scenario that
you could think of and and the bubble
idea you know that is that has been
knocking around now for a good week or
two and you know they're conceived
considered the same thing and in soccer
abroad in England and that I think that
kind of ramped up the discussion because
it emerged over the weekend that you
know English soccer seriously
considering this and and it kind of
brought more attention to the fact that
people in the NBA had already been
talking about it but just as a practical
matter I mean let's just imagine let's
fast-forward to July pick a date in July
July 15th even if they go to Las Vegas
this has been suggested Las Vegas has
the hotel space Las Vegas is where the
annual G League showcase is so the
league is used to a league already knows
what it's like to bring 30 teams
together and have them all playing games
on multiple courts in Las Vegas so
they've done that before but for this to
happen you know
players coaches staff from 30 teams
referees all the operators of the
broadcast who would be making these
Bruck because obviously they want to
televise all this I mean you're still
talking a numb we're talking thousands
of people still can you get all those
people into one city quarantine them and
ensure that they are all healthy and
they all stay healthy and no one gets
the virus again it's just really hard
you know I am no epidemiologist but it
is really hard to imagine that coming
into fruition so these just how serious
are are these conversations just to even
take the figurative temperature check to
use the phrase of the day I mean they're
serious they're serious in that look and
and I totally understand this viewpoint
I mean I don't know what the end I don't
know I don't know that it would benefit
the league to just come out and say
we're cancelling the season now I mean
why not give yourself every opportunity
to play out the season if you can I
don't there's really no upside into just
cancelling so why not have constant
meetings constant discussion and tell
all 30 teams that you know throw out any
idea you have we'll listen I mean Adam
silver has made it clear that everything
is on the table he's he said that and
that's his approach but I'm just trying
to be a realist and I think if you
listen to voices around the league the
people who are talking about this
publicly I think you know players would
have a lot of safety questions our
players going to feel safe going into an
environment like that I mean I I just
think there's a healthy degree of
skepticism just because the situation is
so dire I mean it's obviously a
worldwide crisis and in terms of sports
it's you know it's the biggest crisis
that global sport just has ever faced I
mean that's not overstating it right and
and in the NBA because it is a global
sport
and also with the NBA in terms of the
schedule the NBA also had a prominent
player test positive for coronavirus
first the NBA also had a player test
positive for the corona virus with
people in a building getting set to play
a game they were the first to shut down
I mean they kind of after the Ivy League
the day after I think the Ivy League
decided to cancel their entire
tournament in order to determine who was
going to the NCAA tournament though we
all know eventually got canceled as well
the NBA was the first here and they're
kind of the first and I know the NHL has
a similar construct but the NBA has a
huge or spotlight on it to be very
honest so the question is is is the NBA
going to be the first to cancel games as
well you even said that they're just not
ready to do that yet what's the
conversation on that front mark yes I
don't know that you you know maybe maybe
there is a ribbon and tons of praise for
being the first one to come out and say
we canceled
I suppose you know in some corners you
could say that that would be some sort
of PR victory for them maybe but I I
mean the the clear sense coming from the
league is at least at this point you
know three plus weeks into this the
calendar just slipped to April they do
not want to rush to cancel they want to
give this every chance and I think the
one thing you can say is there isn't a
time crunch yet there will eventually
the league will eventually reach a point
when it says you know what trying to
save this season is just going to mess
up next season too much but there is
that faction around the league and you
mentioned Mark Cuban and he's been very
vocal about you know Mark Cuban is one
of those guys and he's not alone that he
is he is one of the prominent people in
this league who loves the idea of
starting next season at Christmas and
going through August and pushing free
agency into September and there is there
is a you know a faction of people within
the NBA that would love to see a broad
calendar change which is not something
that the NBA can just Institute that
something that has to be collectively
bargained with the players but because
of these emergency circumstances it
could arise that the NBA has to try out
that schedule and give it a test drive
and see so there are people in the
league who say you know playing games
we've always wondered what it would look
like to have real games in July August
and September have the draft much later
have summer league later start at
Christmas so I think there there is
there are some people in league who want
to try all those things and meet
circumstances could force that necessity
being the mother of invention in other
words on that front that huh mark Stein
here for the New York Times on the Rich
Eisen show but then there's the concept
of cancelling games because let's get
into this a little bit even though
there's there's a lot of legalese and
we're talking about collective
bargaining or even the words force
majeure and putting putting aside money
in an escrow account if you cancel games
then perhaps there's a money-saving
aspect of things to take salaries and
take them and put them in escrow can you
describe what I think I think you know
the biggest reason to try to save the
season is because this has already been
a hugely expensive season for the NBA
let's remember how it started it started
with the Daryl Morey tweet that
fractured the NBA's relationship with
China and as the all-star game Adam
Silver said that that event you know
that controversy will cost the NBA in
the hundreds of millions you know
somewhere but you know he estimated
somewhere we you know above 200 million
but less than 400 million but that's a
lot of money and then now on top of this
you know people fear that the losses
when you add up the regular season games
lost the money that would be owed back
to the regional networks that have
regular season games the loss of
television and gate revenue in the
playoffs that this is going to cross the
billion threshold so the withholding
salaries the whole concept of
withholding salaries that's all meant to
try to keep
next season salary cap and the split of
money between the players and owners
those are measures all to try to keep
you know to not mess up next season but
this is going to be a hugely hugely
hugely expensive season for the NBA so
that's a big motivation wide if if
there's a chance to play in July August
and September they want to do it because
it's the chance to theoretically recoup
some of the money they're losing right
now and I guess the idea would be just
to game it out again from what you might
have heard that you take all 30 teams
you quarantine them where they are right
they got to stay at home and then you
test them before you test them
throughout you test them right after and
then you get them to Vegas you test them
before they quarantine there maybe for
another week or two and then everybody
in this community has been deemed Cove
at 19 free and then you play the games I
guess that would be the way to do it
right is that the way that I mean right
now when that's what people forecast is
the most realistic way that this season
can be continued and not just end
abruptly obviously baseball dealt with
this in 1994 through a labor stoppage
when they didn't have a close to the
season it's never happened in the NBA
and naturally the NBA wants to avoid
that they don't want to have a season
that just ends at the 65 game mark with
no champion but again these are all you
know it's still just conceptual because
the NBA and smartly so has said from the
start we can only take our cues from
survivors to really reflect off your
bounce yeah the virus that's that's what
doctor foul Qi says all the time that
the virus that's the timeline nobody
sets a time when the virus is what's
setting the timeline and then that right
and then of course there's the question
in a way you're hearing the NFL getting
a ton of blowback about saying we're
gonna hold a draft I mean just a draft
which does not require anybody to travel
anywhere it just requires people to have
to
reconfigure in in front offices how they
how they conduct the draft movie in the
NFL is a great fortune of you know their
their draft is so far removed right from
you they're playing seasoned writer the
the NBA would love to have it draft in
June but they don't know the order no I
know that might have to be postponed if
if they get any hope that there's that
they can play games in July or August
you got to hold the drought right no but
the thing the reason why I'm bringing
all this up is you still have to realize
also I'm imagining what what the real
world is is like and and how it would we
received to know that dozens hundreds
upon hundreds of NBA players and front
office staff and would get tested in a
manner that maybe you know the regular
populace doesn't and they'd have to
they'd have to figure all that stuff out
to see if it's worth playing a season
amongst all of that right mark and
wouldn't you agree what speaking purely
from a societal perspective let's let's
hope that by July that by the time we
got to that point right that testing
nationwide would not be the issue that
it's been I mean you would like to think
that's the case but again that is that
is certainly not my no no I know I know
that but again in its I'm not trying to
put you in that position but but the
whole idea there is that a lot of NBA
players contest it really fast you know
back in you know a couple weeks ago and
and and I'm just wondering if the NBA
you heard all of that and they would be
factoring that into all the many
questions you're right I think there is
there is the societal component here and
if it if it looks you know the NBA is
not going to rush back and put thousands
of people into a supposedly empty gym if
society you know if so many other
communities are going through shutdown
still and are in the position that we're
in now so they're they're gonna follow
the directive that they get from
government officials and again they you
know I totally understand why you
discuss these concepts why you why you
plan you know you know the contingencies
contingencies upon contingencies is kind
of the
phrasing people throw around right
certainly they're gonna talk about you
know they're gonna brainstorm but you
know they're waiting for direction just
like everyone else
mark appreciate the time stay healthy
stay hearty and I'll give you a ring
shortly we'll check back in with you on
all of us appreciate the call mom good
everybody be good out there you're right
back at you that's mark Stein